this video is sponsored by the language
learning app
babel use the link in the description to
receive up to 65
off your subscription at some point in
all of our timelines
the lights turned on for the very first
time
it isn't clear exactly when or what it
was like because that first moment of
complex consciousness
has long since lapsed our memory but at
some point
everything began to become some form of
everything for the very first time
the world or rather our mental construct
of the world
began and in this birth from nothingness
into our subjective color of everything
we became both the creator and object of
our worldview
we see the world not as it actually is
but how it is painted by this unique
lens of consciousness
inexorably bound to it our view and
experience and understanding of
everything
is created by our interior experience
created by our consciousness
created by the natural world in a
reflexive continual feedback loop
and so the world as it actually is
exists
at least in some major part behind a
sheath of subjectivism
this is not to suggest a solipsistic
stance that the physical world does not
exist outside of consciousness
but that the particular image of the
world we experience
this color would not we see the world
not as it is
but as we are wrote 20th century author
anna esnin
ultimately we are in something that we
can seemingly only touch through a body
and know through a conscious mind
forever prohibited from contacting it
outside of our personally filtered
experience of it forever stricken to the
methods of perception our brain allows
or can create
forever condemned to the persistent
illusions or hallucinations
that come as a result for good reason
likely this exact reason one of if not
the primary
distinct quality of our complex form of
consciousness
appears to be its ability and desire to
inquire about and into itself
the world and the relationship between
the two
it wants to know what things really are
how they are and why they are
it wants to dig and dig and dig until it
hits the innermost core
and knows all there is to know finally
able to understand and control the
mechanisms of existence
toppling or rising above the very
substrate force through which it is made
and freeing itself from the necessity of
further inquisition
but what if in fact there is no such
core to be reached
or if there is but it cannot be reached
by us
[Music]
of course there are plenty of things we
can know and be right about
in plenty of different contexts i can
point to a blue pillow and say that the
pillow is blue
and since most of us share eyeballs
optic nerves occipital lobes and human
brains
that generally function the same when it
comes to visual processing
we can agree that i am right however we
can't actually know that what we see
is the same blue because we cannot see
into each other's minds
and know that although we both agree
that we see blue we are actually seeing
the same mental experience or qualia
of what we are calling blue this and all
other problems related to the disconnect
between our perception
and what is really outside of our mind
is known as the egocentric predicament
which is further extended and made more
difficult when considering what is
experienced in other people's minds
by the concept known as the explanatory
gap which is the challenge in explaining
the subjective experience of physical
phenomena
sufficiently well enough to translate
what the experience is actually
like to another person and so even here
in this simple everyday obvious example
we can't confirm that anybody is
objectively right
furthermore someone who is severely
colorblind might not agree that the
pillow is even any type of blue at all
to them if they do agree they must agree
not out of their sense of truth
but a willingness to sacrifice the truth
of what they see for what the majority
of the rest of the species sees
and tells them but fundamentally are
they really wrong if they say the pillow
isn't blue
what if all humans were colorblind or
what if the pillow is in fact a much
more vibrant color of some other
wavelength that we can't even imagine
let alone perceive wouldn't we all who
say it's blue
then be just as right or wrong as the
color-blind individual who says it isn't
this is all to say that even though
there can be derivative truths derived
from sufficiently shared subjective
experiences
about which one can be right i.e the
pillow is blue
and the very same sentiment at the very
same time the same someone can be
fundamentally wrong
and if somehow suddenly we could all
perceive different higher wavelengths of
color
and we all agree that the pillow was in
fact not blue
then we would all also agree that anyone
who still said it was
would be wrong even though the pillow in
itself
never changed how many things in the
conceptual atmosphere of political
moral economic metaphysical and so forth
are blue pillows what are we all
colorblind to
and what have we all agreed is true
simply and only because
we all agree that it's true what is
underneath all the different shades of
blue
green red and all the rest this is not
to say that such agreements of
perception
and value judgments aren't majorly
useful and sufficient in many
if not most cases but it is to point out
the off-putting fragility
or at the very least malleability and
abstractness
of all of what we think is true there
are of course
ways of measuring and getting closer to
apparent fundamental truths of physical
reality
through tools theories and methods that
supersede any sort of perceptual
illusions biases and so forth but also
of course
all tools must start and end through the
first and final tool and method of the
human mind
there is no way out of the mind and thus
there is no way into the world
as it actually is and moreover it would
seem that if we could understand and
explain
what and how all the physical stuff of
the material world
is we still wouldn't necessarily be any
better off
knowing what it ought to mean and so if
all human truths are based on agreements
of shared subjective
internal experience which are all
limited inexorably by human perception
then we can likely never know if there
even is a core of objective truth to be
reached
or at the very least if we conclusively
ever reach it
if there is and if this is the case then
would we not
in every effort towards such a goal of
fundamental axiomatic conclusions of
reality and truth
be endeavoring the impossible and
consequently is not attempting to think
and talk in generally true objective
terms
also impossible not useless but
impossible in the absolute sense
if we cannot arrive at any grand
fundamental objective truths to life
but we must build all conclusions ideas
and discourse on top of some sort of
foundation
this places discussion thinking and
believing
on a constantly shifting unstable and
widespanning ground of various types
of subjective ideological world views
and this absurdity at the core of all
world views likely then spider webs into
the attempt to discuss and think about
even relatively commonplace ideas
built on or within such a system of
thinking
this phenomenon potentially reveals
itself when we confront another person
who is so obviously wrong
but has no idea how they could possibly
be so while at the same time
is equally certain that we are in fact
so obviously wrong
even though we have no idea how we could
possibly be so
or perhaps when we confront a sudden
breaking down of what we were so majorly
sure about for so long
realizing that everything we believe
individually or collectively
is in fact entirely opposite to what is
now apparently true
this is learning if it ends but some
kind of madness if it never does
of course it is obligatory to mention
that all of the aforementioned ideas
could themselves be wrong
they might entirely oppose what you
believe or feel you know to be true
but ironically if anything that would
seem to potentially support the main
point here
in either case for the most part knowing
what the real color of things are
metaphorically speaking is perhaps
minimally relevant to living and
thriving
as an individual and collective species
perhaps what matters is that we can
agree on subjective things
sufficiently well enough and cordially
enough often enough
and also somewhat ironically it seems as
though in order to do so
if such a feat is possible the
prerequisite is a willingness and
embracing
of often being wrong naturally and
culturally
the desire to be right is a deeply
enduring and forceful one
as often as possible sometimes at all
costs
and often times in spite of good reason
we are both compelled by our psyche
and pressured by our social
circumstances to always be right
and when we aren't it hurts so much so
that it can often create horrible
sensations in the brain
akin to that of real physical pain and
so we of course try to avoid it or at
least
admitting it at all costs and yet it is
impossible to avoid
and furthermore it is possibly the case
that fundamentally
we are never actually right at all in
the words of saint augustine
i er therefore i am as
a consciousness in the form that we are
born into we are all put up against the
imperative of our mind to desire
absolute truth
while simultaneously the seeming
imperative of the natural world
that prohibits us from obtaining it
we will all cling to reasons and answers
and world views
just to have them smash to pieces time
and time again
whether we know it or admit it to
ourselves or not we will all likely not
only be wrong often
but right rarely even in the meta
subjective sense
and so perhaps we can and must learn how
to be okay with this
if we wish to be okay with consciousness
perhaps we must learn how to
fundamentally be okay with being wrong
or we will loathe ourselves until the
end perhaps we must love and accept the
hypocrisy that runs through the very
veins of the human condition
or we will hate all of humankind perhaps
we must learn how to dial back our
expectations
and the degree in which we dread over
the inevitable failure of everything we
believe
and the beliefs of others just the same
this is not to make light of the immense
challenge of such an arduous endeavor
it is an endless upward climb of
surpassing one's default mode
and understanding of the world but
perhaps if we can
at least some of the time succeed in
doing so we can feel a little less
embarrassed
disgusted miserable ashamed bitter angry
and all the rest and perhaps we can be a
little less wrong
a little more often
this apparent impossibility of
successfully thinking
paired with the inability to ever not be
thinking
seems to beg the question is
consciousness a gift or a curse
or perhaps some combination of both
perhaps the answer depends on whether or
not
all of this the ability to be curious
about and discuss things like the
possible impossibility
of ever truly being right is worth
possibly never being right about
anything and perhaps such a truth
can only be answered by you
it is enough for me to contemplate the
mystery of conscious life
perpetuating itself through all eternity
to reflect upon the marvelous structure
of the universe which we dimly perceive
and to try humbly to comprehend an
infinitesimal part
of the intelligence manifested in nature
albert einstein
this video is sponsored by babel
there is a huge list of reasons why it
is useful and enjoyable to learn new
languages
perhaps you travel or want to travel to
foreign locations and cultures
where it would make navigating and
conversating with the locals far more
comfortable and enriching
perhaps you are or want to be in
business or creative collaborations with
individuals across different languages
or perhaps you want to learn a new
language for personal reasons
like interests in particular cultures
and arts or to simply expand your
cognitive capabilities
and understandings of the mind there is
no shortage of reasons to learn a new
language
but the problem is how time-consuming
and challenging it can often be
babel however is a language learning app
with over 10 million worldwide
subscribers
that makes the learning process
accessible efficient convenient
and effective babel provides courses for
a wide variety of different languages
and unlike other apps that often use
machine learning algorithms
babel's lessons are created by over 100
language experts from around the world
voiced by actual native speakers of the
languages
additionally lessons aren't filled with
superfluous fluff
but are focused on preparing you for
situations that you will actually
encounter in real life
in only a short amount of time you can
absorb and recall phrases
pronunciations spelling cultural
contexts and so forth
making it great for beginners and more
experienced speakers alike
learning a new language is not only
known to improve focus cognition and
memory
but it can also provide an interesting
and insightful broadening of your
framework of the world
and mind how the utterances of different
sounds can mean nothing to one person
and something important to another and
how these entirely separate sounds can
come together
and exchange shared meaning in order to
learn the other
whatever your reasons are for turning
babel into meaning babel
is a fantastic way to start and or
continue your journey
towards learning new languages if you're
interested
by using the link in the description
below for a limited time
you will receive up to 65 percent off
your subscription
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video
you